what's going on people Kevin Hart here
at baddies comedy cope obviously I'm not
here by myself with some talented
comedian Greg Coleman Earl Ellie who's
Leroy Williams and I leave so time 1 we
family I'll live in Minneapolis but I
moved here 13 you go 13 years ago from
Yemen how long you been doing comedy I
attempted it 70 years ago but I've been
action for the last five years define
that so people can understand that you
say so the first year I didn't like
seven open right that doesn't help at
all okay I don't learn anything from
going off seven times a year
okay they have to do at least seven
times a week I think just get started so
what inspired you to start doing
stand-up did somebody else help push
into the direction or were you like you
know what I just want to give you a shot
I just want to be a stand-up as a kid
but I grew up in a half letting house
man I had uncles throw ball my father
was pro ball boy look at you like yeah
man you ain't prepping the family name
we play ball I mean he's jokes so he was
a fun okay cousin you got to call him
out stop talking like you thought did
land if you had to describe your style
of comedy going to be majority of the
people in the world grow up in the
struggle and that's what I talk about
growing up struggling okay
I quit my job not knowing that any of
this was know that man today marks two
months two months being out
entrepreneur we fret we fresh off fresh
super fresh do you feel like is
important for an audience to leave
understanding who you guys are very much
would you rather audience leave just
saying oh my god he was the funniest
person ever I don't do it for them I do
it for me okay
yeah like if had if I worked at a bank
I'd be sitting outside talking to myself
smoking a cigarette look like a crazy
person yeah I go on stage this where
that's for me and if they like it they
like it what does this moment mean to
you oh man it's literally history
because no one has ever been on TV from
my country
okay who has not been like on an FBI
like most-wanted
I'm excited to see you guys perform
tonight
I'm here as a supporter man so without
further ado let's get to it man
[Music]